welcome back to the special edition of
Piers Morgan uncension with Andrew Tate
one on one so Ash sarkar who's a a
lively contributor to this program as
tweeted Andrew take here you're
interviewing about Free Speech thinks
women are a man's property we shouldn't
be allowed to drive both about only
dating teenagers to imprint on the
misogynists are discussing whether
they're in Afghanistan or a Swanky
London Studio
am I a misogynist am I I don't think I
first anything she said I don't even
truly believe it's I can if you're
prepared to listen to me I'll explain to
you exactly why she's not really
completely utterly wrong if you can go
through the points against you do you
think you're a misogynist absolutely not
I'm not a misogynist on any level this
is one of those buzzwords they throw it
in they just throw at people randomly
homophobic races misogynistics throw it
out at people what is your view of women
I'm a realist what's your real view of
women I absolutely not only love women I
adore women I have good relationships
with women not a single woman has come
up to me on the street since I've been
canceled not a single one has said
anything negative every single one of
them has said positive things or a
traditional male I wish more men were
like you you understand your masculine
roles you understand what you're
supposed to do you understand you're
supposed to protect women you're exactly
the kind of man I'd be looking for I've
never had a negative interaction with a
female ever since I've been dubbed the
biggest massages where is the please
please let me finish I'm sorry sorry
Pierce also there's not been a single
woman who's accused me of a crime not
single woman's accused me of rape not
single woman's come out and said
anything from my entire past of 36 years
I've done anything wrong ever anybody
else with my level of Fame any football
or any other movie star at least has
people who've come out and accuse him of
rape XYZ I have no woman who's come out
and ever said I've hurt her no woman has
come out and ever said I've done damage
to her or been horrible to her everybody
who ever interacted with me has said
I've been a nice person all of them so
this random Twitter nobody who seems to
know so much is full of all right you've
responded to her Twain yeah where is the
line for you between masculinity which I
will always defend and which I agree
with I think a lot of women like men to
be masculine and and what has become
known as toxic masculinity the reason I
ask you is that you are engaged in that
debate with men all the time where is
the line for you where men shouldn't
cross where the behavior should be kept
within a line please define toxic
masculinity well you tell me what you
think it crosses a line from being a
masculine good man to a bad man there's
no such thing as too much masculinity if
it's genuinely masculine genuine
masculinity is not out here to hurt
people it's absolutely the opposite it's
out here to protect and when bad things
happen they call traditionally masculine
men if you need a firefighter you need a
masculine man when you call the police
because of the problem you have you want
masculine men and as soon as a woman or
a man is in trouble when you look for
backup you look for masculine men and
masculine men have a duty to provide and
protect those they care about we have a
duty to do things we don't feel like
doing because we know we're supposed to
do them and that's why we stayed in the
Titanic and died those were masculine
where did you get your views about this
from because what I grew up with is the
family I grew up around and the father
your mother yeah and the world I lived
in and I think a lot of the things I'm
saying now about masculinity and how
people should act in the world how the
world should function we're considered
completely normal and accepted by
everybody only 20 years ago I think the
world's just lost its mind for me to
stand up and say a man should protect a
woman now gets to be called a misogynist
and canceled if I said that 10 years ago
everyone would say duh and what's funny
is everyone who argues against me and
says men shouldn't protect women
especially all the feminists if they
were with their boyfriend and a man
broke into their house guess who they'd
expect to go downstairs
who do you think think they go
themselves are they going to Afghanistan
no we send men to do these things women
we send women in the armed forces too
would you have to generalize when you
make points there are many many
exceptions exceptions do not disprove
the rule no but they're you've got to
concede there are many courageous women
serving in the arms absolutely and
utterly completely correct but by and
large traditionally soldiers are men
exceptions do not disprove the rule
well it's not an exception it's the fact
that there are a lot of women on the
Armed Forces correct but if you were to
take the average Soldier they are a male
if you're allowed to say who's a male
and who isn't nowadays I'm assuming
their gender I apologize if you ever
take the average Soldier they're a male
which means that exceptions are the
female soldiers which because there's a
lower percent of them a lower
probability exceptions do not disprove
the rules men do the fight right now in
Ukraine men cannot leave women are
allowed to leave because men have to
fight in the front line and women are
allowed to go to Dubai that is how it is
what do you say to young men who come to
you for advice you feel lost you don't
really know where they fit into society
I say that life as a man is
exceptionally difficult I say the most
beautiful and the most terrifying thing
about being a manager born without value
Society doesn't care about you you're
only going to be cared about based on
how useful you are you have the chance
to build yourself up and become a
superhero if you're prepared to do the
hard work and be indeigable enough to
never quit but if you're going to stand
around and wait for a handout nobody's
going to ever respect you and I think
that a lot of people have forgotten
about how difficult and how competitive
it is as a man always in constant
competition with each other and it's
your duty as a man to stand up and say I
want to be as important and strong and
good-hearted and God-fearing as possible
and I need to work hard to achieve those
things David Sheila Hancock says we've
become too over emotional as a society
crying too much about everything yes you
got a point she's completely right and
the dangerous thing about overly
emotional men is that they're dangerous
they're genuinely dangerous this is
what's crazy all these people who talk
about toxic masculinity and how bad it
is for men to be traditionally masculine
a traditionally masculine man does
things he doesn't feel like doing but
because it is his duty to do them he
charges into the burning building
because it is his duty not because he
feels like it because it is his duty
we're now teaching the new generation of
men that they don't have duty and they
can just act on their feelings and act
how they feel and they don't have to act
as a man should do you know what happens
when you get men who just act how they
feel you get School shooters you get
violence you get rapists men who do not
control their emotions are dangerous if
you find a man who is stoic he's not
going to hurt people he's going to sit
and think about his actions very
carefully and he's going to be a good
man who protects for and provides for
his family you find a man who just acts
out on impulse and does whatever he
feels like you're going to find a
dangerous man sitting here telling men
to cry more and act with their feelings
and it's okay to feel this way that way
Etc and have no self-control that is why
we have the problems we have in the
world absolutely not they're wrong so
when they talk about toxic masculinity
they have it completely inversed on its
head completely nutly wrong we need to
be teaching stoicism we need to be
teaching young men to understand that
the world is very very difficult it's
hard to be a man you're going to feel
bad sometimes you just suck it up and
perform anyway not to sit there and cry
your eyes out or blame other people
certainly talk off being a woman but I'm
not a woman so why would I speak on
issues I do not understand I'm a man you
can feel an empathy for women I feel
empathy certainly but I do not
understand their issues a lot of men
come up to me and they admire you I've
got to say a lot of women I've spoken to
don't admire they think you represent
misogyny they think when they hear you
not commit to saying the Taliban
shouldn't be banning women from
University education why can't he just
say that's wrong well firstly that's not
my experience I experience the absolute
and utter opposite of that secondly it's
because it's a moral point I'm making my
moral point is I speak on things I
understand I speak on experiences I've
had would you believe in equality I
speak yes sure I speak on subjects I
know intimately I do not feel qualified
I'm a realist and I do not feel
qualified to sit and discuss the gender
laws in Afghanistan I have not been to
Afghanistan I have not researched the
subject thoroughly I'm not going to sit
here and say how their Taliban should be
running their country it's nothing to do
with me I find it quite flattering peers
that although you know I understand I'm
monumentally influential the most Google
on Earth Etc I find it very flattering
that you think I have some kind of
control over the domestic policy of
Afghanistan but I assure you I don't I
don't no no I'm not asking you to have a
view on having influence of a domestic
policy I'm sure the Taliban couldn't
give us stuff what either of us say
about it um it's just curious to me that
it's an easy win for you to make women
think you're not anti them to say that
when they're not given equality as the
women in Afghanistan clearly are not
because they're not allowed to go to
university now as of today that is
clearly unequal unfair we should all be
able to agree that that is wrong well
certainly even you tough guy Andrew not
tough guy I am a professional as a
professional I can state that yes it is
not equal yes it is not fair that is
obvious for anybody I'm not saying those
things are not true what I'm saying is
it's nothing to do with me right okay
but you've made a concession you think
is wrong it's wrong I said it's unequal
and it's unfair yeah so wrong well
perhaps force yourself Andrew no perhaps
it's wrong under certain moral
guidelines but under the moral guideline
things which are currently in charge of
the jurisdiction of Afghanistan they
don't believe it's wrong it's nothing to
do with me well then I'm not going to
sit here and tell other countries how to
run their laws I'm going to live in
societies
you know what I'll take unfair and
unequal sure because that's
self-explanatory